[Applause]
wow
thank you very much i uh
i think i love you too and i think i
know why you're happy that i say that
every week
this week i think because you did not
invest in crypto that was a very wise
thing yes
crypto
i was hoping for this it's horrible for
the environment you know it's just
[ __ ] stupid and it
has crashed like a rock they've lost
almost a trillion dollars i mean people
in the metaverse are jumping off virtual
buildings it's rough
and you know who got it millennials
because they thought it was cool
and now they're like wait you mean it
was a bad idea to put all my savings
into an imaginary currency uh
with a dog on it uh
but you know what's doing good the
actual economy
you know where people buy [ __ ]
and make stuff yeah
yeah
the economy grew 5.7 the most since
1984. of course we still have problems
inflation for you know supply
but you know workers they can't get
enough workers and listen to that
in this country that's still paranoid
about the virus they're pressuring
workers because they don't have enough
to go to work when they're sick i think
i saw it the other day at the
supermarket the guy who bagged my
groceries asked me if i could help him
get to the car
but yeah i know people people you're
suffering the inflation right i mean i
did you see this dollar tree
dollar tree
it's not funny sir people need dollar
tree dollar tree is raising the price of
all their stuff to a dollar 25. what
why'd you call it dollar tree i mean
i feel like you could see this coming
you know i i've said you know 20th
century fox
[Laughter]
sergio mendez in brazil 66 can't you see
that it's not in the future
you just you just look 2 000 late you
know
but anyway
they're raising the price of everything
at the dollar show to 1.25 they're
getting very bougie about it
they're not calling their expired
toothpaste vintage
[Laughter]
and don't get me started on m m's
you know what i realized how much i did
not know about eminem's this week
everyone's talking about [ __ ] m m's i
i've had one since i was a child okay i
didn't realize they have characters did
you all know this
okay i'm sure all right i'm not i'm that
guy who doesn't know this kind of [ __ ]
but i didn't and so now eminem's are
yeah there they are they're making them
more inclusive
inclusive
there's six of them of different colors
they're male and female some have nuts
some don't how much more inclusive can
you get
and
i'm telling you
i'm i'm just learning all this
i'm i just the green one
apparently uh there had to change
because she was [ __ ]
[Applause]
really see that she had like eye makeup
and high heels well that's all gone is
anyone out there saying
is that eminem trying to [ __ ] me
you